ainsi vous qui le dites spéciales 1
coupe du monde nous sommes aujourd'hui
avec la communauté portugaise d'orléans
précisément dans un bar situé à saint
jean blanc que pensent ils de leur
équipe
que pense-t-il des bleus de didier
deschamps quel pronostic pour la finale
on leur donne la parole et ça s'appelle
ses boutiques vite
[Applaudissements]
en 1998 le portugal n'avait pas
participé à la coupe du monde
à l'époque vous souhaitiez quelle équipe
la france bien évidemment c'était pas
que j'étais pas né
j'étais même pas en préparation donc
aller dans ma tête c'était la france
alors où étiez vous le 12 juillet 98
donc j'étais bas dans ce café dans ce
bar parce qu'à l'époque mes parents y
tenait le bar ajouté en ville sur un
écran géant on regardait la france gagne
et donc sa première coupe du monde
orleans louis bal à la maison en famille
autour d'eux
dans mon petit barbecue d'un apéro et on
regarde le match quand beaucoup de
beaucoup de français beaucoup de
portugais
vous avez remporté l'euro 2016 face à la
france quels souvenirs gardez vous de
cette victoire au stade de france il ya
deux ans il y a deux ans donc c'était
c'était le lendemain c'était mon
anniversaire
ouais et puis bah je garde un bon
souvenir parce que voilà la victoire ça
a été
l'un de mes meilleurs cadeaux mitigé
j'avais adoré parce que le portugal a
gagné et malheureusement la france a
perdu donc c'était aux dépens de la
france j'aurais préféré limite que la
france garde un peu avant comme ça au
moins c'était pas le portugal gagner
contre eux quoi bad et vos souvenirs
le premier du portugal j'ai l'âge de
m'en souvenir
après une finale perdue au portugal face
à la grèce on la gagne en france avec un
beau public et voilà c'est notre
première victoire européenne donc
les sacre national donc on a tous cette
fierté
ce même si c'était contre la france
quelles sont les chances du portugal
pour ce mondial de 2018 s'ils continuent
sur leur lancée on va dire que ils
peuvent aller très loin en quarts de
finale si tout va bien on peut taper la
france enfin jouer contre la france qui
est une grosse équipe j'ai envie d'y
croire mais après moult et voilà au
niveau haut niveau au niveau tactique
j'ai peur que ça risque de coincer un
moment ou un autre et les bleus de
didier deschamps vous y croyez ouais bah
on y croit plein de petits jeunes pleins
de petits jeunes dont un petit jeune
florian turin qui édifie d'orléans donc
mon frère il a joué avec quand il était
petit à ingré individuellement c'est une
équipe très très costaud
après est ce que didier arrivera à faire
une bonne mayonnaise de tout ça un
pronostic pour la finale
j'espère pas france portugal espagne
portugal voit ça serait bien
rebelote belette ouais je crois en
france brésil en chine et peut-être
allemagne
peut-être allemagne portugal allemagne
c'est le pronostic de vigueur je pense à
un brésil espagne
esi l'espagne ce pronostic de félix je
pense rendez vous le 15 juillet 15
juillet merci à bord merci à vous
car vu à la télé
voilà un honneur surtout dans le
meilleur bar au monde merci au revoir